it's good to be back in Europe thank you
for inviting me here today for this
important discussion you're not in the
congressional hearing you've come to the
European Union and there's a big
difference we are here in terms of
regulation and the United States is here
[Music]
[Music]
as we need to know in Europe the true
scale of the violations of users data by
third-party apps you need to get an
estimate of this we've already
investigated thousands of apps and as I
said earlier we've taken down more than
200 there were many thousands more that
we need to investigate this is going to
take many months I was disappointed by
the format there were many questions no
answers the conversation format as such
was too short too flat and in so far the
responses of mr. Zuckerberg were not
substantial enough are you ready to
completely comply with the new
regulation in Europe in the next three
days we do expect to be fully compliant
on May 25th so in three days from now it
was not helpful for the users in
European Union we didn't get clear
answers in which way Facebook really
wants to apply to the roads of gdpr if
these big data machinery allows third
parties to buy off your personal data to
profile you collectively and to target
you as an object of political influence
then this is undermining the sovereign
right of democratic nations
[Music]
you
[Music]